[Music]
stupid the world of competitive dance is
no joke and Dance Moms is living proof
of that
Kindle and Brynn's rivalry got way out
of hand in season six and seven and
their mothers only added fuel to the
fire keep watching to find out the truth
about the room follow vertes feud you
stupid you know what season six of Dance
Moms was a total GameChanger
not only did Brynn rom follow and her
mother Ashley become new ALDC members
but the Ziegler sisters decided to throw
in their towels with Maddie gone the
number one spot was up for grabs and
Jill sincerely believed that her
daughter was a shoo-in problem is Abby
Lee Miller had her eyes set on Brynn who
she believed to be a better dancer
Brendan Kendall didn't really have any
issues with each other but once their
mothers started bickering the girls
quickly chose sides
Jill was angry with Abby's decision to
groom Brynn for the number one spot
whereas Ashlee was tired of being picked
on for having a talented daughter the
entire season was a mess and the drama
carried on into season seven Jill and
Ashley were constantly at each other's
throats which encouraged their daughters
to do the same it's old news that Dance
Moms is somewhat scripted which is why
we're curious to find out whether or not
the feud was authentic pyramid days are
never fun especially when Abby Lee
Miller is in a bad mood but in season 6
episode 13 Abby Lee did something
completely unexpected she praised her
dancers Abby congratulated Brynn for
leading her team to victory and
everything was going smoothly until
Ashlee made a comment that set Jill off
Ashlee and Jill went back and forth in
front of the kids
which led to Kendall screaming in
Ashley's face Kendall's outburst was
super real and it only strengthened the
feud between her and Brynn we later saw
Brynn crying in her mother's arms she
told her mom that she wished she could
scream and Jill space-like that it's
safe to say that any tearful moments
that go on between the girls are
legitimate whereas the
between the moms is more uncertain I'm
over it
something's got to change after the
fight Jill and Kendall left the studio
and threatened to leave Dance Moms but
the next day Kendall and her mother came
back to the studio with a different
mindset
the mothers talked about how their
actions were inspiring their daughters
to lash out in anger and they went on to
say that they should never fight in
front of the girls
Ashley chose to be the bigger person and
apologized to Jill but their feud was
far from over
Kendall and Brent's tears might have
been real but according to the girls
their mothers fights weren't always
sincere since Dance Moms has a
reputation for being scripted it's not
surprising to find out that the fights
between the moms are hyped up from time
to time during an interview with IBT
Brynn opened up about the drama being
short-lived she said that the fights
don't last forever and that they're just
for filming purposes she also stated
that once the scenes are wrapped up all
the moms are friends again and everyone
goes out for lunch but you know what
we're in Vegas let's celebrate it's
clear that the show's producers aimed to
create a rivalry between Kendall and
Brynn with Chloe gone and Maddie leaving
Dance Moms was losing its dramatic edge
so a new one was created in season six
and seven Jill was put on blast for
bullying Brent
however the dance mom was quick to state
that we shouldn't judge someone based
off of their TV personality according to
her her bullying was blown out of
proportion still there are times when
Jill and Ashley's actions were out of
control although some fights are
scripted the mothers did nothing to
prevent Kendall and Brynn's rivalry but
the Dance Moms weren't the only ones to
make a bad situation worse after all
Abby Lee did choose to pin Kendall and
Brynn against each other at the
beginning of season seven Abby pointed
out the fact that a rivalry could push
the girls to be the best she commented
on how playing nice never got anyone
anywhere so Abby pushed the girls to
fight for their spots on the team
claiming that someone would get cut this
brought the drama to a whole new level
and before we knew it Ashley and Jill
were at each other's throats all over
again
Ashley made it clear that she thought
Brynn was the next Maddie and this
statement drove Jill absolutely crazy
according to Jill kendall was being
groomed
to be the next star and brynn was at the
bottom of the ladder but since Bren was
a marvelous dancer
Jill was clearly just threatened by her
so she constantly picked on brim in
season 6 episode 18 jill threw a fit
when Brynn was standing in front of
Kendall during rehearsal Jill even went
as far as to say that Brynn didn't have
her brain in her head
Jill scolded bread in front of everyone
and when she tried to explain herself
Jill told her not to talk back to adults
honey don't talk back to a grown-up just
say okay I'll stay out of her way well
turns out that Kendall could have used
this advice as well after all she did
more than talk back to Ashley she
straight-up yelled in her face although
it appeared that Brennan Kendall wanted
nothing to do with each other this was
far from the truth
as a matter of fact the girls were
actually friends Kendall shared some
snapchat videos of her and Brynn hanging
out back in 2016 and the girls were
clearly having a great time during an
interview with IBT Kendall said that all
the drama went in one ear and out the
other
she also confirmed that the cast didn't
let the drama get to them because it was
just a TV show despite all the drama
Kendall and Bren have been seen hanging
outs as they both left Dance Moms in
2017 and - believe it or not but Ashlee
and Jill are far from being the enemies
that show portrays them to be before you
go let us know who you think had the
best Dance Moms rivalry Chloe and Maddie
are Kendall and Brennan and that's a
wrap don't forget to hit that subscribe
button to give this video a big thumbs
up thanks for watching the things we'll
see you next time